bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag agir
aujourd'hui pour les générations futures
le développement durable permet de
mettre en oeuvre des mesures sur le long
terme tout en adaptant les modes de vie
la mobilité le logement l'agriculture ou
encore la reconquête de la biodiversité
le but mieux vivre tout en combattant le
réchauffement climatique
alors comment s'opère cette transition
écologique à saint quentin en yvelines
ont fait tour c'est parti
[Musique]
en octobre dernier les experts du giec
tirait la sonnette d'alarmé
il est urgent de prendre des mesures
sans précédent afin de limiter le
réchauffement climatique de 1° et dont
le rôle de chacun j'ai commencé à
prendre et poncé ans maintenant et j'ai
fait vraiment beaucoup très attention
par rapport à ça et on était toutes les
lumières on essaye de faire du tri au
niveau des ordures et la mobilité
tout dépend en fonction du temps que
j'ai en fonction de la distance
donc si c'est pour aller sur paris mais
je vais plutôt prendre les transports
pour souvent le train parce que c'est
beaucoup plus économique les transports
en commun pour éviter la voiture et les
logements
quand on est au tout électrique c'est
compliqué
c'est un poste coûte cher
malheureusement la halle du verre va
répartir dont je vais encore beaucoup
plus dépenser c'est quelque chose qui me
tient à coeur c'est aussi le rôle des
territoires pour y répondre les
collectivités mettent en place un pca
petit plan climat air énergie
territorial celui ci définit les
objectifs et les actions pour limiter le
changement climatique et s'y adapter
l'état exige des collectivités une
réduction de 40 % des gaz à effet de
serre par rapport à 1990 une baisse de
20% de la consommation énergétique par
rapport à 2012 une croissance de 32 %
d'énergies renouvelables dans la
consommation d'énergie finale à saint
quentin en yvelines le pc a ôté a été
votée en septembre dernier pour six ans
le plan climat air énergie territorial
est vraiment transversale sur toutes les
compétences à la fois de la collectivité
donc sa part que ça parlera
d'aménagement on parlera de mobilité on
parlera de paysages on parlera
d'alimentation on parlera d'économies
que nous soient entrepreneurs habitants
agriculteurs ou collectivités les
agissements quotidien de chacun sont
prises en compte dans ce pc halte est
l'objectif
à partir de là et de pouvoir définir un
certain nombre d'actions qui vont
permettre à chaque compétence de pouvoir
faire l'action de réduction
de consommation d'énergie et puis à la
fois d'adaptation parce que c'est un
truc concret le plan climat c'est pas
juste un énième plan qu'on mettrait au
placard derrière ces objectifs seront
mesurés au fur et à mesure des années
mais avant cela un game no stick
s'imposent afin de connaître l'existant
cet état des lieux a nécessité deux ans
de travail sur l'agglomération
celle ci a travaillé en collaboration
avec l'ensemble des acteurs des douze
communes qui la composent
premier constat la mobilité on
s'aperçoit par exemple que d'à peu près
plus de 90% des habitants saint quentin
en yvelines utilisent leur véhicule
personnel pour des déplacements de moins
de 5 km on a énormément d'imagination à
trouver d'imagination sur le
développement des mobilités ce qu'on
appelle active aujourd'hui le vélo la
marche à pied plusieurs pistes se sont
envisagées plus de pistes cyclables de
stationnement sécurisé et plus de lieux
de location pour les d'euros mais aussi
des lieux de pause pour les marcheurs le
développement du véhicule autonome et
d'un réseau de trottinettes électriques
au sein des gares sont à étudier
[Musique]
deuxième constat la consommation
énergétique des bâtiments
pour cela nous nous sommes rendus à la
lèque l'association de l'énergie et du
climat à montigny-le-bretonneux
la plus grosse partie des logements
étaient en crue entre 75 et 95 donc
effectivement avec des normes
énergétiques qui ne sont pas celles
d'aujourd'hui c'est le manque
d'isolation qui est reine et des
dépenses de chauffage particulièrement
important gamins qui sont allées des
chaudières à gaz individuel d'hôtes avec
du chauffage collectif et puis d'autres
encore
en tout électrique des énergies fossiles
qui risque de fortement augmenter à
l'avenir
la lègue propose un bilan énergétique du
logement afin de définir les travaux
prioritaires
grâce à la plateforme repères habitat
les particuliers se voient proposer des
ateliers avec des professionnels du
bâtiment tous labellisés
on va les accompagner dans leurs
démarches travaux de a à z du moment où
ils ont l'idée jusqu'à la fin et même
après avec un suivi des consommations
pour vérifier que les travaux étaient
efficaces mais quels sont les plus
efficaces
on pense tout de suite à l'isolation de
la toiture et aussi après par les murs
et les deux postes principaux de
perdition avec les fenêtres aussi depuis
la rentrée les saint quentinois peuvent
prendre connaissance des déperditions
énergétiques de leur logement
en mars dernier un survol avec caméra
thermique a été effectué sur
l'agglomération afin de connaître les
points de déperdition des toitures sur
les habitations c'est vraiment un outil
d'information pour soi et de
sensibilisation on consulte la
thermographie auprès sur demande auprès
d'elle est qu'avec un conseiller qui
aident à analyser les les hypothèses
pourquoi cdp relatifs à ces endroits la
preuve à l'appui une fois par mois le
samedi matin à particulier ouvre sa
maison afin de présenter les travaux
effectués et les bénéfices obtenus
l'alec propose également de se
sensibiliser aux bonnes pratiques grâce
au défi famille énergie positive
l'objectif de ce défi national est de
réduire de 8% sa facture d'énergie en
pratiquant les éco gestes
exemple mettre des rideaux aux fenêtres
éteindre l'éveil à la maison
l'utilisation de multiprises par exemple
où on va brancher plusieurs appareils
qu'on pourrait atteindre en même temps
mettre des mousseurs au robinet pour
diminuer la consommation d'eau des
givrés son réfrigérateur ou encore
mettre un couvercle sur une casserole
lors de la cuisson et réduire d'un degré
la température d'une pièce un petit
degré en moins pour 7 % d'économies sur
sa facture pour ce défilé famille se met
en équipe entre amis entre voisins entre
collègues
85% des familles engagées réussissent le
défi troisième constat l'agriculture
plus de 20% du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines est agricole un
atout à transformer l'objectif est
d'avoir un certain nombre d'actions
concrètes d'accompagnement des
agriculteurs pour qu'ils se diversifie
pour qu'il développe l'offre de circuits
courts qu'il développe l'offre de
production pour la consommation locale
qu'il développe aussi la possibilité
d'alimentation locale
je pense par exemple à nos restauration
collective pour nos écoles de manière
générale
à l'heure actuelle 10 % de l'agriculture
saint-quentinoise et bio une production
qui devrait se développer davantage
grâce aux divers plans mis en oeuvre
mais vraiment liens forts avec des
agriculteurs
certains agriculteurs se convertissent
totalement sûre du bio d'autres le
feront un peu moins c'est notre rôle
aussi de avec en tant qu'habitant tout
simplement de pouvoir leur demander d'y
aller concernant les points de vente en
direct une quinzaine d'amap existe
actuellement sur saint quentin en
yvelines plusieurs épiceries
participative se met aussi en place des
nouveaux modes de consommation qui qui
apparaissent et et qui se développe de
manière très régulière sur le territoire
ce qui montre aussi un changement de
pratique des habitants et peut-être une
attente aussi de leur part
[Musique]
pour faire face aux pics de chaleur
comme c'est tt saint quentin en yvelines
possède un maillage écologique appelé
aussi trame verte et bleue espaces
boisés arboré aquatique
une richesse qui favorise la
biodiversité
saint quentin en yvelines possède 60%
des espaces naturels des espaces
aquatiques boisés ou encore des chants
et des étendues d'herbe un véritable
atout au coeur de la cité est un verte
et bleue au niveau des espaces
aquatiques évidemment il ya de
l'évaporation donc une humidité ambiante
qui rafraîchit l'atmosphère pour tout un
chacun et au niveau de la trame verte
que ce soit les espaces arborés qui
apporte à la fois de l'ombre et de la
fraîcheur par évapotranspiration on
n'oublie pas non plus les espaces en
herbe et les espaces en terre qui
restitue aussi une humidité ambiante et
qui évite la réverbération de la chaleur
directe et cette sensation étouffante de
chaleur qui émane du sol des murs etc
ces corridors écologiques constitué par
cette trame verte et bleue permettent
d'intégrer les déplacements de
nombreuses espèces est de maintenir la
biodiversité n'a pas encore d'outils on
va dire quantitatif ou qualitatif de
suivi de la biodiversité
on a néanmoins des études ponctuelles au
fur et à mesure du développement de
l'agglomération et de la construction du
territoire qui nous indique que nous
avons quand même une biodiversité
intéressante sur le territoire l'enjeu
est de la préserver tout en poursuivant
le développement du territoire la ville
de demain
sera différente de celle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui pour la simple et bonne
raison c'est que ces fonctionnalités
doivent
prendre en compte les problèmes
climatiques les espaces naturels
aujourd'hui ne sont plus seulement les
lieux de décors qu'ils étaient
auparavant pour pour les habitants ils
ont une véritable fonction à l'intérieur
de la ville et doivent participer au
règlement de certaines problématiques
notamment les problèmes de pollution on
a oublié malheureusement en construisant
nos villes que nous n'étions pas seuls
sur terre et qu'il y avait avec nous une
biodiversité et pour préserver les
espèces mais aussi la santé des
habitants l'agglomération a renoncé
depuis dix ans aux produits
phytosanitaires pour se tourner vers la
gestion différenciée des espaces verts
des tombes plus tardivement effectués
dans la saison et non ramassés pour
conserver l'humidité au sol et servir
d'engrais ou encore une prairie en herbe
est haute les jachères urbaines sont
autant de refuge pour les abeilles
papillons et autres oiseaux qui viennent
s'y nicher des conseils valable pour les
particuliers également fini les
pesticides herbicides et autres
fongicides on arrache à la main les
herbes envahissantes
mg on plante des arbres relevant
d'espèces locales pour réduire la part
des déchets verts incinérés chaque année
le territoire lancera début 2019 un
vaste plan de compostage à tous les
habitants composteur en pavillon au
coeur des immeubles ou des quartiers une
équipe accompagnera les riverains
soutenus par une association ou maisons
de quartier
jardin et compost certains sont déjà
passés à l'action comme ici à la maison
rousseau de plaisir avec un jardin
intergénérationnel créé à l'initiative
de la crèche familiale
donc là on est dans le jardin partagé
qu'on a inauguré au mois de juin
on a commencé au mois d'avril avec les
enfants et les assistantes maternelles
ainsi que les seniors à cultiver et on
dit plutôt content parce qu'on a fait
une belle culture notamment de tomates à
profusion des tomates mais aussi du
melon des salades des condiments enfants
de moins de 3 ans et seniors se sont
appropriés ou réapproprier la terre
pendant tous les ateliers de l'été les
pique nique etc
on a mangé les tomates du jardin c'est
quand même une magie fille maintenant
c'est devenu tellement tellement facile
d'aller au supermarché récupérer mon bas
là on voit que ça nécessite quand même
du travail
les enfants eux ça reste avec le jeu
donc je fais des petits trous dans la
terre vit mais les graines les seniors
il sera approprié pas c'est plutôt il
revient ils y reviennent parce que
beaucoup ont quand même connu l'époque
où où on cultivait encore les petit bout
de jardin ils ont le goût quand même
et pour couronner le jardin le compost
qui va avec
ce dernier est alimenté avec les repas
du midi du personnel et avec les restes
des ateliers cuisine on est novice a
évidemment il ya personne qui est qui
est formé pour ça mais on essaye comme
les particuliers de de se mettre à la
tâche pour arriver à terme à faire de
l'engrais et pouvoir justement au
printemps l'utiliser pour preuve d'une
bonne récolte
l'écologie c'est la sphère de touche
bien évidemment un petit geste de chacun
contribue à faire que demain nous
vivrons mieux la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et l'adaptation
à ce réchauffement parce qu'à un moment
donné il faut être aussi réaliste il y
aura un réchauffement
mais c'est la responsabilité de tout le
monde et donc la responsabilité de
chaque personne soit à titre individuel
ou collectif dans le cadre
d'associations d'entreprises et du coup
tout le monde doit pouvoir participer à
cet élan qui est le plan climat la
première action du pca est et sera le
lancement de la plateforme eskimos
c'était qu'au laboratoire de la
transition énergétique du territoire
permettra à chacun de prendre
connaissance des actions lancées et de
les suivre
eskimos se veut une interface
collaborative et participative
chacun pourra donner son avis et
proposer ses idées
rendez vous le 11 décembre pour son
inauguration à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]